for years populist said been advocating
tighter border controls within the
European Union which EU and the national
governments have criticized yet in 2020
that is exactly what we're seeing
happening it all started with Italy and
border controls being imposed from
people trying to leave Italy to go into
Austria but since then a host of other
EU countries have done exactly the same
we have seen Slovenia Hungary at Denmark
and now even Germany shutting up shop
saying its borders are closed Schengen
which is the idea of free movement
within the European Union to do that
without passports is essentially over
well for now at least the future I don't
the borders at the entrance of the
European Union and the Schengen zone
will be closed
concretely all travel between non
European and European countries will be
suspended for 30 days we are forced to
stop flight connections to these
countries and establish controls at the
Swiss border just like the ones we have
already implemented with Italy Hungary's
border in the direction of Italy remains
closed without a valid risen traveling
in and out of the country will no longer
be allowed imposed a ban on entering the
Czech Republic for all foreigners except
foreigners with a permanent residency
permits or residency permits for over 90
days life in the EU as we know it is
over museums shops bars cafes schools
have all shut up shop in many countries
in a bid to pause this peak of the
infection rates in France the bees which
is the way that people sort of greet
each other with kisses on the cheeks has
been pretty much banned people have been
awkwardly bumping elbows or knocking
their heels together but even that has
been petering off as people are becoming
more and more whipped up in hysteria
that they could get contamination from
just being close to another person the
government's line is keep your distance
from each
yet in the EU this conglomerate of 27
countries which are all meant to be
singing to the same tune it doesn't seem
that there's one rule that all are
applying even the European Commission is
warning that the closing of borders
could actually pause supplies thousands
of bus and truck drivers are stranded at
internal borders on parking lots
creating more health risk and disrupting
our supply chains if we do not take
action now
shops will start facing difficulties in
refilling their stocks of certain
products coming from elsewhere in the
single market some see the idea of
governments in Europe essentially
locking down their countries as being
the start of a slippery slope even
warnings that this could be a nail in
the coffin for globalization as we know
it the coronavirus crisis threatens to
usher in a less globalized world once
the pandemic and panic abate those who
believe that openness to people and
products from around the world is
generally a good thing we'll need to
make a case for it in a fresh and
persuasive ways and he says this could
be a gift for populist parties who have
been advocating this this tighter
control of borders for many many years
and also those tighter restrictions
kovat 19 has highlighted the downsides
of extensive international integration
while fanning fears of foreigners and
providing the disa massif or national
restrictions on global trade and flows
of people Europe historically has been a
cultural hub its bars its cafes its
restaurants Hayes's of people coming
together discussing and debating ideas
and some fear that this idea of self
isolation as with being told to do could
actually cut through the fabric of that
some have also said that it will see the
nation fighting lowliness as people self
isolate in their homes and their
apartments now in Italy some people have
already tried to overcome that we've
seen these marvelous comes together of
people singing on their balconies as
there's a sense of we're in this
together
[Music]
[Applause]
but the longer that self-isolation goes
on some say could be weak some say it
could be months for many people their
homes which are meant to be their safe
haven the place that they go to relax
and rest could become more like a prison
cell future historians will remember the
time 1990 to 2020 as the heyday of
European global integration which came
to an end free borders of free movement
integration inclusion etc and all of a
sudden we see a complete this this mode
goes into reverse the consequences will
be grave no question I do not expect any
return to the status quo ante we will
see a different view I do not expect a
disintegrated Europe but how this will
how this will work out how it will look
in in reality for example with border
controls that's a completely different
question
Remy days of the past with no border
controls at all I see as permanently
over gone
you